بيني
طبا
يعوي جوه
الغا ج يقول
لي
b
همشي اجمع توقيعات لحد كل الناس ما تخش
احلفي وامشي في الشوارع دي فضحك واخد نفسي
في
الفي واجري في الحديقه واي المغرب الشقي
وارمي نفسي في حضن نفسي هي الصديقه هخش
احس راب ده حلو قوي ما تقلقوش عليا انا
فيا م حاوي
بالطريقه هقول
الحقيقه وهسمع
شبقه وهزر
سريقه هتفرق ايه ما كل الناس بتقول
حميها
حراميها
عشان ماشي في الشارع وصدري داق من
الهبال عشان كمان تهرب من بتاع النور في
لحظه
الحساب عشان الدنيا عجيبه وكل حاجه ناقصه
باب عشان تايه جوه صحرا وجير الميه
صرا
بس
هقدر ققول
الحقيقه صراب
هيكبر ويبقى
حقيقه هتفر ايه ما كل الناس بتقول حاميها
حراميها
k
h
ا
كل يوم الصبح س ب ام النوم مهموم جدا
تعبان
بوليا لو اليوم يوصل
منتهاها ب لي فتره دايه جدا حاسس بغربه عن
الحياه والعالم مش فاهمنا انا ها جو اجلام
كتير لكن نخرس مش عارف اقوله ولا
مجهول
والحاضر
والمستقبل مش معلوم وما بص في المرايه لا
واحد تاني دير انا
ماعرفوش من اول نظره انا
محبتهوش انا مافيش حاجه ليا اللي جابني
هنا ما انا عايز اخرج من العالم ده
ب انا مافيش ح
ليه اللي جابني
هنا انا عايز اخرج من العالم
دبا
كل يوم الصبح بقوم من النوم مهموم جدا
تعبان
بوليا لو اليوم يوصل
لمنتهى بقي فتره تايق جدا حسب غربه عن
الحياه والعالم مش ماهب ل انا جواك كتير
لكن ن اخرص مش عارف اقوله ولا
مكو والحاضر والمستقبل مش معلومه وما بص
في المرايه لا واحد تاني غير انا
مفوش من اول
نصران انا ما فيش حاجه ليا اللي جابني
هنا انا عايز اخرج من العالم
دهب انا مافيش حاجه ليا اللي جابني
هنا انا عايز اخرج من العالم ده
ب
شكرا
مره ابويا قال لي يا ابني انت كل سكه
بتمشي بيها بترجع ضايع ليه كبر مخك خليك
انسان عادي محاسب ضيع بقى القاضي راح تاخد
من حلمك ايه لو ماسكتش المسيكه خلي حياتك
كده انتيكه وانسى عا النجم كده المصاريف
مش مكسوف من نفسك وانت بتط الطط على
المسرح وانت بقالك في الكليه سبع سنين
عمال بطيع عمرك ولا احلمت كده اكلت مخك يا
ابني بطل تحلم قل لي امين امين قلت يا عم
تفكك مني كل ده يعني عشان كده غني يعني
انا كنت انا هعمل ايه انت عشان م الجيل
السلبي فاكر نفسك تير حربي والنبي سيبني
في اللي انا فيه انا في هموم الدنيا
خلقاني احلامي ما هي سايباني انا انا زل
كانش دار كنت ماشي في الشوارع مش عارف
اعمل ايه محتوم الناس من اهدي كل اصحابي
من الدنيا من حتى البحر ليه كنت ماشي ماشد
واحد لسه طالع حالا يتطوح مسالي
سكر وفي وسط كله واحد واححد بيعمل زي
الناس على الحيطه انت عايز اقول
له روح تقابل
ساندي
ساندي كل يوم الصبح تقوم تشرب على الريق
براندي الكره الارضيه بالنسبه لها مش اكتر
من مجرد حبايه يوست فندي الياس مدمرها
ملغبطه مدمرها ملغبطه تمام و جايه الحد
عندي تحضني وبتقول لي ما تيجي نموت انا
وانت ونرتاح قلت لها ارحمي
امي شايف مدينه مصريه تدق بال الاكب
والبؤس
ليه شايف مدينه مزريه تطك فيل
والبس موتوسيكل مشغل مهرجان ومعلي على
الاخر احي
افاس
k
ا
في
السفه عشانك غنيت بلوزه وحطيت البيبي كينج
فوتني بقيت بقول على نفسي كتري
بوي وجبت بدل جيتر جيتين عملت عليهم احلى
ستين جبت الواد الفس على الترعه قلت له
وركس يا بوي جبت البيتلز جبت حبايبي
واخوي وجبت الواد جوني كاش وعملت اليفن في
تطور
ببلاش ك في
السفه
والوقف سماني مهووس سر كان رول وانا شاب
يا ناس من صغري مش مهووس انا زي الفل
انا بحلم اجيب الكدلك وامشي بيها في
البحيره واشق بيها الحلم الضايع وخرا
بيتشخ ما بش صايع ورقص وتحرج جوه النغم
انا اتزبط واستغنيت عن بكر البط وبقيت
باكل روك ان رول حتى الشيطان اللي غواني
جاله
السل وفي يوم من الايام ماشي في شارع ع
احلام شفتك ماسكه في عيل لابس اسود اسود
من قرن الخروج ورافع صب عينه في عيني
الوده سجيل ماشيه مع حم المديل شعره مربي
في صراصير دكت قلبي بقيت مزامير ما بقتش
انا عارف اعمل ايه
ليه
h
ا
شكرا غلباوي وكل الناس واقفه على دماغي
وعلى لساني ولا اعرف حتى ايه فيا كابتي
شبه رباني لوحدي ماشي فرداني ولا اعرف حتى
عنواني ولا احلامي
سيباني ها وطيلي من غير سماعه وماشي في
جيبي ولاعه ونفسي اصل طماعه ما بتهدش وما
بتجري وهي بتيجي في منامي وبصح بعوز انام
تاني يا مين يعمل لي احلامي حياوي سيبني
فيها
اعيش
وعقلي خلاص بقى خرابيش وتوها وقفن حشيش
ويجي 10000 ترويش وسكه طويله ما بتمشيش سر
عشان دخل في احلامي ورغم ده كله ما بجليش
ويجي واحد يقول لي ما
فيش ده انا مخي اصبح شارع في كده هنا كشك
المواجع بيسترزق وبكون م مانع فبيح مرق
وبيعمل قال مش سامع افكاري واقفه حزينه
ناقصها نشاط وما فيش بنزينه بقوللك ما فيش
حاجه علينا اوعك برض تقول لي مافيش
والدنيا دي دوره بتلفلف من غير اماره
وبتغير في نفوسنا دايما وبتولع من غير
شراره يا عم فهم وبلاش غباوه بلاش حج ياكل
ب عقلك حلاوه ب
ب
عمرو
منير
k
شكرا
he
السعاده جايه اهي ماسكه شنطه فيدها فيها
انفيتيشن للحياه واست ميشن لعب كوره في
الحواري والشوارع عديمه زي واحنا صغيرين
كانه احلى فيلم
سيما اول مره سقط وامسح الهم
وارمي كل حاجه وحشه في القمامه واقلع
الكمامه واشن ريحه بحر فاضي ل جوه
اسكندريه حاله سعاده
حقيقيه مش
تمثيليه
كل مره فيها بكبر بلاق اني فهمت اكتر ان
قدر بايدي اني لازم اتعب وافكر في اللي
جاي وفي اللي راح همشي ورا شمس الصباح
ارقص والعب مسيكه رايقه مش هتزاول في
المضيقه هبطل فرجه على التليفزيون كلامه
بقى زي الافيون واقول لكل حد اناني انا
ماشي يا حلاوه بردون اغاني غنوه عن الامل
حتى لو ما فيش امل احول احب بنت مجنونه
وتبقى من برج الحمل
اغني
اغني اغني غنو عن الامل حتى لو ما فيش امل
اغني بن وعن الامل حتى لو مافيش امل اغني
غنوه عن الامل حتى لو مافيش امل اغني غنوه
عن الامل حتى لو مافيش يلا كله معايا غني
غنو عن الامل حتى لو مافيش امل كله معايا
يلا اغني غنوه عن الامل حتى لو مافيش امل
اغني غنوه عن الامل حتى لو ما فيش امل غني
غنوا عن الامل حتى لو ما فيش امل
غني غنو عن الامل حتى لو مافيش امل غني
غنو عن الامل حتى لو ما
فيه